- Do you know how
many people I think here
should quit their job,
take another job
that pays them less,
sell their home,
go rent an
apartment that's shittier.
'Cause no one walks
outside and be like,
"Yo, sold my fuckin' house!
Going to rent an apartment now!"
(rap music)
("Three O' Five" by Jakc)
- Good to see you.
How have you been?
- [Man] Australia.
- [Gary] Yes, we're doing it.
- [Man] So the Melbourne Cup
is their big horse race,
and the country shuts
down, and views overlapping,
and they said it...
- [Gary] Dude that will lose.
We will not! We won't lose!
- [Man] You're good
but you're not that good.
- [Gary] 100%! I totally get it.
- Good to see you, man.
- Good to see you!
- How was the flight?
- It was good! I was dead.
AJ had his baby last night!
("Three O' Five" by Jakc)
- [Man 2] Yeah,
I could certainly decipher it,
but you know,
I think we...
- I mean, when you only get
two hours of fucking sleep.
By the way, real quick,
while I've got all of you.
I sleep six to seven hours.
It's not how much I sleep,
it's what I do when I'm awake.
I just wanna say it
over and over and over,
'cause so many people are like,
"Do you sleep, do you sleep?"
I fuckin' sleep.
Last night, I didn't sleep
because obviously
the amazing news with AJ,
and then I had to wake up
so early to get to Atlanta.
But when I don't sleep
I've got to do, like...
You know what's crazy?
I already have the
natural like, dark eyes.
Like my family has that.
And then like, I'm
just like, so you know,
- [DRock] Compounds.
Yeah I'm just
like everyone's like,
"You need to sleep, looks
terrible when you hustle!"
There's plenty of people that
hustle that look beautiful.
- [DRock] Are there?
- Yeah, me! Me!
You're looking at one!
I mean, there's
nothing I like more
than what I'm about to do.
As much as I love
running a business,
as much as I love
you know, everything,
that feeling is insane.
This will be more
about how I got to the place
of being an owner--
- Cool!
- of the agency.
Like more of like,
"Why are you sitting here?"
Or it's all about
work ethic, really.
- Yes.
- It's very interesting, I was
just talking with him about it.
So many people.
Like I use motivation.
I get it from sports,
I get it from hip hop,
I get it from other places,
but people get it, like
you've got to be careful of
not making it the only ...
- [Rob] Got your clothes on?
(Gary laughs)
- We went to college together.
[Woman] Oh wow!
- Rob.
- [Rob] How you doing?
Nice to meet you.
- [Man 2] Now we all (mumbles).
Didn't know you went to college.
- Mickey.
(laughter)
- I'm Chris.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Man 2] You went to college?
- Let me know. Let's
talk on email before.
- [Woman] Nice meeting you .
- Such a pleasure.
Have a great time.
- [Man 3] Thanks
for taking pictures. `
(low-key hip hop music)
- Send me an email on that.
I'll send it out to you.
(Gary laughs)
I love this guy!
You're gonna love this.
I'm gonna turn off my mic.
- Where did you guys go to
school with legal inspectors?
- Please tell him.
Please, once and for all,
please set the record straight.
Please help everybody understand
what I really navigated through.
Can you please tell them?
- It was six months,
not even, five months
of a bunch of people
that shouldn't be together
together at one time.
- You're talking
about 301 right now?
- I'm talking 301, I'm talking
about the whole school.
(laughing)
Had people that didn't
deserve to be in college.
Didn't deserve to be at a gym.
Didn't deserve, they were--
- To be in society.
- Yes. They were in dorm rooms.
- Mickey, I'm telling you...
- Kids who just
did the mixture...
- Who was in charge of
admissions at this point?
At the school (mumbles)
- Dude, I don't
think that you understand,
do you know how I got
into Mt. Ida College?
I got a postcard in the
mail and I filled it out.
- That's how I got in.
(laughter)
- March of my
senior year is like
what are we doing with college?
I'm like mom, what
are we doing with college,
you knew that the
process starts sophomore year
of high school.
She looks at me she goes,
"You're going to
fucking college."
I'm like fuck.
- No SATs. It's
one of those schools.
- Yeah, no no, no no, Moose,
please tell my friend Chris
here how many...
what percentage of
kids on that campus
do you think spent time in jail?
Start with that number.
- Before or
after they got there?
- In life.
- It was like yeah,
it was very interesting.
(group laughter)
Characters. They shouldn't ...
- [Chris] Smoky the bear.
- They really shouldn't,
have no business...
- Truly, literally
from the first day,
you want to
talk about chemistry.
- My first day of college,
I walked in hated it.
I went in three days
late because they had the
ice cream social
and all this other crap.
So I didn't show up on time,
I'm not going to
ice cream social.
(Gary lauhgs)
So it was like, I go into
my dorm room and I look on
my bed and this
guy's laying on my bed,
he's all up on my bed.
And at that time
I wasn't the happiest person.
(group laughter)
Try to go to school and
trying to be cool, you know.
And I see this guy on my bed
and I was like, "God!"
(group laughter)
What is going on here?
And I'm looking at him,
he's not moving.
(group laughter)
I'm like what, okay.
And I look at my
roommate, who got a...
- You got to
understand his roommate.
Black kid, like rapper.
Like has a bat.
(laughter)
Like ...
- Yeah, yeah.
- Where's Steve Rat from?
- He's from, it's a--
- You remember?
- [Man 4] Gary, we had
a saying in college ...
- Westbury.
- [Man 4] Which was admit
nothing, deny everything,
and immediately
make counter accusations.
- Yeah, listen, that's
fine except this was a school
where like a
person will stab you.
(group laughter)
Like it wasn't...
Like this is not Virginia.
Like this is...
(group laughter)
- [Chris] There's
so many stories ...
(laughter)
you hear it from ...
- [Man 4] I'm just saying,
I'm saying like take that...
- Our one friend got
kicked out of school.
How many pounds of
weed he had in his room?
- Not that much.
Like three or four pounds.
(Gary laughs heartily)
- More than I've
ever seen in my life.
- You have to
understand that answer.
Like Nick Dio's talking about
like I had an ounce on me.
He had four pounds of weed.
I'm sitting in a room,
playing Super Star Wars
on Super NES.
And the cops are
coming, and I'm like...
He'll tell you, I never
did a single piece of drugs
in my entire life.
These guys would
sit in a room like this,
fucking smoke
forty blunts to the head.
Never wavered.
- Never.
There was no over under.
- [Man 2] Wait, so
the cops came in?
- Wasn't going to happen.
- I got out.
Cops came in.
- Wait so you
have to pause the game.
- I mean we were
doing crazy shit.
We were like, we were
putting 30 packs of Bud Light
through the window.
Remember we were
doing so much shit,
but like everybody did that.
The extra element was
fifty percent of the kids
went to jail in their lives.
That's a different element.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- Like most people went to
college with nobody they know
went to jail.
Like they don't know a
single person that went.
And these...
- [Man 3] Or it's
like a night in jail.
- Yeah, and people went to
jail for battery, burglary,
attempted murder.
- [Man 3] It's not just...
Like people didn't
go to jail for DUI.
- [Man] For weed.
- What else is funny?
- All kinds of things.
He would break
people in the craps games...
- Oh.
- This guy didn't like to lose.
They didn't
have that much money.
- This is a real story.
- [Man 4] And you beat him?
- All the time.
And 'til it got to the point
where they didn't like it.
(laughter)
- And one night...
- You got to tell
the rest of the one night.
- One night they came to get me.
(indistinct chatter)
- Thank you.
- They were mad.
- What do you think...
- Butter cue?
- Yes. And what do you
think I was going to do
to defend myself?
Zero.
- [Man 4] You weren't
in Mike and uh ...
- Forget about shape, even
even if I was in this shape
there was nothing
I was doing to these guys.
- That's crazy.
(Gary laughs)
Maybe like that?
- Back then you were a monster.
You had pecs. Uh.
And yeah man, there was some...
You know something we
played a football game.
First of all,
we were ridiculous.
We became this pack, 301, right.
We were in this dorm.
And we walked around school,
you got to
understand it's the second day
of like normal school.
To Moose's point,
first three days or whatever.
Second day of normal
school and we're walking like
fifteen guys deep.
And we're like, we're a crew.
- Right ...
(group laughter)
- [Chris] Undergraduate probably
like 5,000, less?
- What's that?
- 5,000 undergraduates, right?
- Less, right?
- Yeah, it was small.
- 2,000 maybe, 3,000.
Anyways, we're walking
around, we're walking to the
cafeteria like 301!
Like real ridiculous, right?
But like other
people didn't like it.
So what did that lead to?
We had to have a football
game to settle the score!
When I tell you the entire
school knew about this game.
- Whole school!
Went to watch this
organized game of Malloy Hall
versus Brown Hall.
Right?
So we play the game.
(laughs) This is the best story!
We're playing--
- The Ambulance Game?
- Oh, right.
Early on, somebody got hurt,
or was that how it ended?
- That was in the middle.
- Yeah, anyway--
- Cross-eyed Chris!
(group laughter)
He kept a mess a game.
- Yes, the replacements!
That's what it was!
We're playing,
I come in for a play,
I even think it
might of been you!
You were like, "Don't fuck up!"
(laughs)
First play,
I get an interception.
First play.
Cool, we don't do it,
nobody is moving the ball
because fucking
quarterbacks we did not have,
and people are
just getting drilled.
Glenn Larboy was a quarterback.
They controlled, none the less,
second series, I get a pick,
and I get open space,
and I'm like going.
Problem is, as
you can probably tell,
every kid on the
field was faster than me.
So, even though
I had open space,
this kid, their
running back, caught me.
I would have scored, but
he caught me pretty easily
a good 20 yards
from the end zone
even though it should
have been a clean touchdown.
But I'm hyped, so he tackles me,
and I'm pumped,
and I throw the football at him
like I'm excited.
(group laughter)
He, you know, this is Mount Ida.
He didn't like that.
Before he even got,
seized up for us to fight,
I looked back.
Every single person,
every single person in my crew
is on the field
running to fight,
and his roommate,
Erak, has a bat.
(laughs)
- He didn't like the game.
- He didn't play the game.
He didn't play the game,
the best part is,
no, no, no, the best part is,
I forgot about this, we were
talking about this after.
We didn't know he had the bat.
(laughs)
He's just like, "Oh, really!"
- [Male 3] "I've
been waiting for this!"
- You have to understand,
these are true...
You know what's so funny,
because of the way I do--
- They kicked
you out of the game
across the field--
- Yeah, I...
(laughs)
This is a field of degenerates,
and I'm the only person that
got kicked out of the game.
(group laughter)
Reverse discrimination.
- Yeah.
You should have a--
- Chris, when I
tell you, when I tell you
if I was doing a
daily vlog back then,
it would be the greatest com--
- [Chris] Did you ever, does
the college ever hit you up?
- Yeah.
- [Male] Like, we can--
- I think they're gonna rename
it the Vayner University.
100%.
That football game was all time.
Most of them, you
know what's crazy,
most of our stories are
from that first semester
of freshman year.
It was that impactful.
Our dorms are
right next to each other,
like, our rooms within this quad
were right next to each other,
and at 11:30 P.M. every night,
when everybody would
wind down, go hook up,
go to sleep, go smoke,
whatever they would do,
me and Moose
would go into his room
and play seven
game series of NBA LIVE.
Seven game series.
Every night, battles.
- Yep.
- Pimpsy, all that.
- [Woman] Hey Gary.
- Hey guys!
Yep.
Are you gonna take this off?
For 45 minutes?
- Yep, 45 minutes,
then we have a car ready.
- [Rob] Orchestrating a trip.
(group laughter)
- You did!
- [Woman] Alright, you ready?
- Yeah, I'm ready.
Now I'm mad.
I'm gonna kill this audience.
(group laughter)
Wish me luck.
- Alright, alright.
- One thing that I really
like is they're 60 seconds on.
That was so genius.
- Thank you, brother.
- That was fucking genius.
(audience cheering)
- How you doing, Atlanta?
I genuinely believe and
I know that all of
you are gonna be like,
"Well, I'm in the 10%,"
but I genuinely believe
that 90% of this audience
is spending way too much
time trying to fix the sink
when the well is broken.
You're good if life's awesome,
if you make enough money,
if you like your
work-life balance,
if you like the
people around it.
If you're good, you can take
everything that I have to say
with a grain of salt.
When I point to the phone,
I mean the current
state of our universe,
and the access we
have to reach anybody,
to sell anything you want,
to do what you want to do.
Entrepreneurship.
I'm looking around the audience,
and there's people
that remember 1994.
Entrepreneurship wasn't real.
Nothing most people do
now existed 10 years ago.
There was no going
through your Facebook feed.
There was no
YouTube consumption.
The only reason
I loved the process so much is
I was because I was
hungry and ambitious.
But what got me
through my 20s and 30s
was I didn't give a shit
about what anybody
thought about me.
I have zero to no
tolerance and or interest
to seduce you and
make you feel good up front
to convert you later.
Because I just want
you to work 15 hours a day
if the ambitions
coming out of your mouth,
map to working 15 hours a day.
I'm asking a very basic thing.
Are you interested in
putting in the work ethic
that maps to the ambition that
is coming out of your mouth?
That's it.
That's number one.
The reason so many
people at first don't like me
is because I don't
want anything from you.
There's no such
thing as passive income.
(audience laughter and cheers)
I wanna put you in one place.
If you can wrap your head
around what's going to happen
over the next 10 years.
How many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years
and, before you raise your hand,
I don't mean that
you're gonna figure it out
and crush it and
become a trillionaire.
(audience laughter)
I mean you're fucking
old and you're finished.
(audience laughter)
What am I trying to accomplish?
How do I bring
value to people
that paid a price
while you traveled?
Like, how do I
deliver right now?
Let me help you.
If you are the type of
person that "stays reading"
my five books and my videos,
that "stays spending
their money" to travel here
and see people talk that "stays"
in the point of
consuming and being motivated,
you will never succeed.
How many people I think
here should quit their job,
take another job
that pays them less,
sell their home, go rent an
apartment that's shittier,
and take the time
that they get from having
that new job that's shittier
to learn to suck on coffee,
and then come back?
I actually believe that
is the fundamental model
for half this room.
(audience cheering)
Nobody's doing it.
(audience laughter)
'Cause nobody walks
outside of here like,
"Yo, sold my fucking house!
"Going and renting
an apartment, now!"
Nobody does that.
Nobody is like, "Selfie,
my new, shitty apartment!
"Used to have a house!"
(audience laughter)
Not happening.
You're going nowhere if
you're looking backwards.
You know what happens
when you look backwards?
Somebody passes you.
I have zero percent
interest in you doing what I do.
What I do in my vlog
and you watch it,
that is not propaganda for
you to work 15 hours a day.
That's just to make sure that
you realize if you want this,
it's 15 fucking hours a day.
See ya!
(audience applause and cheers)
Thank you!
The truth is always--
(laughter)
I love putting that
pressure on the system.
Let's see what
they do with that.
(Woman laughs)
- You wanna make sure
you get out by one thirty.
- [Man 5] Welcome back to
the stage, Gary Vaynerchuk!
(audience applause)
- [Woman 2] What if your spouse
is not supportive of
your effort to
be an entrepreneur?
- [Gary] (sighs) You know,
what's so amazing,
first of all, thank you
for asking that question,
because that's
gonna help so many people.
You're gonna have to make,
or that person is
gonna have to make,
the decision on how
aggressive they're going to be
with the conversation
that needs to be happen,
which is, you have
to create boundaries
on lack of support is
suffocating and very difficult.
And so, look, I know,
especially grandparents' and
parents' generations of mine,
like 60, 70, 80,
they ate everything.
Right, they ate everything
for, "I do forever."
I think the reason we see a
higher divorce rate than ever
is because people
want to be happier.
I don't have the
audacity to give you
anything but
the truth, which is,
it should be a
non-debatable issue,
that if somebody
that you're spending
the rest of your life with
is willing to bring you down,
you've got macro issues.
- When you, on the other
hand, talked about the love
of the hard work, the
process and the grind,
which is really why I
feel connected to you,
'cause I have a
similar DNA structure.
- [Gary] Okay.
- But with this
more, more, more mentality,
I find it really hard to stop
and smell the roses sometimes,
and tell her how I feel.
So my question to you is.
- [Gary] Can I give
you the advice on that?
- Sure.
- I never stop
and smell the roses.
Do you know why?
I'm always smelling the roses.
(audience applause)
The process is the roses.
The roses isn't
selling the company.
The roses isn't the new house.
The roses isn't the
cover of Entrepreneur Magazine.
The process is the roses.
Now, if you were interested
in some of those events,
spend your money on it.
I would follow every one of
them on Instagram and Twitter
and figure out
what they care about,
because if you
wanna sell me something,
if you start talking to
me about the Knicks, Biggie,
or the Jets, you have
a better chance, right?
So old school sales,
the reason people go and play
golf and go to steak dinners
is to get to
know the person better
to actually make the sale.
Social following of those people
allows you to know
who they are beforehand,
and number two, LinkedIn
ads against the professions,
and then make content
that brings them value.
That's not a sales pitch,
but that's something
that may be information for them
that makes their lives better.
- So more bloggish?
- [Gary] Yeah, but it can be
audio, video, or written word.
Everybody here
who's making content
needs to figure out
if they're a writer,
a video communicator,
or an audio communicator.
I'm all three because I built
infrastructure around myself
'cause I can't write but
I can do video and audio.
So yes, bloggish
if you feel stronger
in your writing
skills, but yes video
if you feel better
in your video skills.
Follow people that
you're trying to sell to
to figure out if
they like fishing,
if they like watching a TV show,
or if they have
four and a half kids.
- [Women 3] And then,
uh--
- By the way, that's the
weirdest thing I ever said.
(audience laughter)
Four or five kids. Keep going.
If you're good at something,
you could always go back to it.
Go suck shit for three years.
Never be 80
and go, "What if?"
and go back to doing
what the fuck you do.
You're welcome.
Because you know
what's cool about that
as you're walking off?
If you go do
something completely different,
when you go back to this,
nobody blamed Michael Jordan
for sucking at baseball.
That's a good one actually.
(audience laughter)
That's the first time I've ever
said that. That's too good.
DRock, got it?
Okay, good.
Fuck, I like that.
("Breathe (Feat. Red Pill)"
by Sareem Poems &amp; Terem)
- Alright, here we go!
Slow, I'm coming!
I'm coming, I'm coming!
My pleasure, you're welcome.
That's the answer.
Got it?
It's arbitrary,
it means nothing.
Three ten, got it?
- [Man 6] Gary, you
changed my life, man.
- [Woman 3] Thank you.
- [Gary] My pleasure, my friend.
Take care, guys.
Good luck to you.
Thank you, thank you.
- [Man 7] Gary.
- Feeling good about that.
Good little talk,
bunch of business stuff.
Everybody's kind of like,
you can almost already see
everybody getting into
the Fourth of July mindset.
Tomorrow will probably be slow.
Vayner Nation, I hope
you're doing super well.
Thanks for being
part of this journey.
Hope you're
getting value out of it.
Keep hitting me up on Twitter.
I've gotten an enormous
amount of interaction there
and continue to enjoy that
and is, no question,
the place to get me.
So, keep doing that.
Thank you for supporting the
podcast and Planet of the Apps.
It means a lot to me.
Big ups to everybody who
is coming to the four Ds.
Did that yesterday.
That's the internal
VaynerMedia consulting product
that we do for a day.
Vayner for the day.
That's been going super well.
Yeah, I love you, DRock.
- [DRock] I love you, too.
- Doing a really good job, man.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- I mean it.
Like, we'll
always forever have this.
- [DRock] We're
in the vortex, now.
- We're in the
vortex, vortex, vortex.
("Breathe (Feat. Red Pill)"
by Sareem Poems &amp; Terem)